it's been the second year since we learned another
form of it, another dimension of it, this is Christmas
in the time of a full-scale
war, a Christmas that has a different mood, a different
context, a different taste and not the same as
usual. A family home dinner is because not
all of us are at home and not all of us have a home, and it has
become  it is much more important not what kind of food is
on the table And what kind of people are at the table and how
expensive it is when they are around and how today is
Important not so much how we decorate
our homes but how we protect our
homes and remove garbage from them
sweep the enemy out of our home how
happy we are when we notice  in the evening
sky the first dawn and we do not see
enemy rockets and
martyrs in it we pray for the end of the war we
pray for victory we will do it
today wherever we are Wherever we celebrate
Christmas today all Ukrainians
together we all celebrate Christmas together on
one date as one big  family as one
nation as one single country and step by
step day by day darkness loses and
in the end darkness loses evil loses
today this is our common goal
our common dream And that is why Today is our
common prayer for our freedom for our
victory for our Ukraine for the day  when
we can all gather at home in the peaceful
year of the Peaceful Christmas and tell each other that
Christ
was born